we're standing right here on the Spanish
Steps where you're standing is literally
where one of the big sequences in the
film takes place are you a little
surprised after what you did in that
sequence that Rome is letting you back
in the city
just a little yes uh uh things got a
little out of hand but we we we we're
always very very careful and we're
always here to celebrate the culture and
to celebrate the places that we visit
and I and I think they took it in the
spirit was it was intended
oh listen when people see the sequence
they're going to be like I'd like to go
to Rome but I'm so curious originally
there was talk that you weren't gonna
the last mission might have been your
last one and I'm curious how did it work
out that a you were coming back and also
that it's a two-part movie was it one of
these things where you came up with an
idea that was so big it would be two
parts and you're like maybe I want to do
this well we knew with fallout Fallout
really grew because of all the character
and emotion we were putting into the
story all the things that we had
discovered in Rogue that were so
unexpected and I knew I wanted to expand
the cast and I knew I wanted to give
each one of those characters more to do
so I knew the movie was going to be
bigger and longer than Fallout and at
which point I said why are we fighting
this why are we going to try to jam this
into two hours Let's just break it in
half and make it two movies that that
really was the the rationale behind it
being a two-part movie it just wasn't it
wasn't just that the story was bigger
but that we wanted more emotion in the
movie last thing for you what did the
studio say when you're like yeah I think
I want to make two
um at that time they were actually very
genuinely excited about it and uh you
know I I think uh I think we were
excited about it too and then there were
times when we were on set and Tom would
look at me and he'd say this was your
idea just remember that yep I don't
think people realize how much it takes
to make one Mission movie let alone try
to do two yeah it's it's massive and
it's and and it was complicated by the
fact that certain things in part two
required stopping part one to shoot them
whether it was because of weather actor
availability uh and so with all the
other challenges that we're confronting
this movie while we were making it there
was the challenge of stopping in the
middle have not even knowing what the
full movie was and trying to predict
what it was in the second film and it's
it's it's a testament to how great this
team is and how patient this guest is
it's really something on that note sir I
love this movie and I wish you nothing
but the best thank you so much